la levée d'un tabou vieux de plus de 60
ans pour la première fois la france
s'engage sur une baisse du nucléaire
c'est ce que prévoit la loi sur la
transition énergétique la part de
nucléaire la part du nucléaire
le nucléaire français le nucléaire
français le nucléaire nucléaire
annoncé comme l'un des textes les plus
importants du quinquennat qui est pour
et qui est contre
avec pour mesure phare une promesse de
campagne de françois hollande propose
l'horizon 2025 d'horizon comparable à
celui des allemands nous ayons diminué
de 75% à 50% la part de 75% de
l'électricité en france est d'origine
nucléaire
un record mondial lors du grenelle de
l'environnement il y a 6 ans le sujet
n'a pas été abordé
aujourd'hui l'objectif est de réduire la
part de l'atome au profit des énergies
renouvelables
le sujet est sensible surtout au sénat
où le texte et romagné
l'atout de la france qu'a été ce
nucléaire il faut le garder
on ne jette pas à la poubelle un tel
atout le tabou de la fermeture de la
première grande centrale française on a
des gens à droite qui ne peuvent pas
l'affronter et on se réfugie dans vingt
délits jugés incontournables pour
certains dépasser pour d'autres où en
est-on vraiment du nucléaire en france
le projet de loi sur la transition
énergétique
un texte très attendu y compris au sénat
ce sont les affaires économiques qui
examine les articles consacrés au
nucléaire
le président de la commission jean
claude lenoir sénateur ump est un ancien
agent edf
le rapporteur ump lui aussi
ladislas poniatowski et le spécialiste
des questions d'énergie au sénat ce sont
eux qui vont mener les débats
cette réunion se situe dans cap l'examen
du projet doit suivre transition
énergétique sujet occupé par un certain
nombre de semaines et les premières
auditions
la baisse de la part du nucléaire de 75
à 50% dans dix ans est jugé peu réaliste
c'est dans dix ans si on veut réduire de
75 à 50% c'est inquiète
la puissance installée donc c'est à dire
sur 63 gigawatts
ces 21 gigawatts c'est la responsabilité
de votre assemblée c'est la
responsabilité de tout un chacun
d'imaginer aujourd'hui quel est le
schéma de renouvellement de ce pas une
position partagée par la majorité des
sénateurs
pour le rapporteur il faut maintenir
notre production d'énergie nucléaire
on a un formidable instrument qui permet
aux français de payer l'électricité
moitié moins cher que le consommateur
allemand nos entreprises françaises de
payer électricité 30% moins cher que
entreprises au monde
grâce à cet outil qu'est le nucléaire
pourquoi s'en priver
non
je
face à la ministre de l'écologie le
rapporteur fait part de ses doutes sur
les objectifs de la loi le plafonnement
de la production de nos installations à
son niveau actuel de 63,2 gigawatts en
plus d'une baisse à 50% du nucléaire
dans le mix énergétique
ne craignez-vous pas madame la ministre
que en gravant dans le marbre ces deux
objectifs vous remettiez dangereusement
en cause la croissance économique pour
les prochains essais dit ségolène royal
se contente de rappeler les grandes
lignes du projet de loi
le choix que j'ai fait dans ce projet
d'oise et de ne pas opposer les énergies
les unes aux autres
nous devons faire monter en puissance et
créer ce mix énergétique à la fois par
les économies d'énergie la montée en
puissance des énergies renouvelables et
le maintien d'une énergie
traditionnelles nucléaire qui nous
permet par la sécurité qu'elle nous
apporte de d'engager et de réussir la
transition énergétique
le sénat fait de la résistance l'avenir
du nucléaire sera bien le point de
désaccord
ce qui n'arrange pas le gouvernement
voulant aller vite sur ce texte avec une
seule lecture par chambre
c'est bien faire prendre conscience à
qui mes collègues de tous bords que
derrière une décision et un chiffre dans
un texte de loi
vous avez ensuite concrètement sur le
terrain une centrale qui ferment c'est à
dire des centaines d'emplois supprimés
quelque part il faut que tout le monde
en soit conscient je fais exprès de
mettre les pieds dans le plat pour les
sénateurs baisser la part du nucléaire
menace la croissance et l'emploi
une crainte partagée par les élus des
régions concernées dans le nord de la
france le tissu industriel est façonnée
par l'énergie nucléaire de la centrale
de gravelines
toutes les entreprises de la région
dépendent
ce soit l'aluminium l'acier
la chimie est là l'industrie
pharmaceutique
on a parmi les plus grosses unités de
production françaises européennes qui
sont installés la centrale de fessenheim
devaient fermer en 2016 cet élu régional
l'a bien en tête
c'était une promesse de campagne mais
elle ne figure pas dans la loi de
transition énergétique
il se souvient des propos de ségolène
royal il y a quelques mois affirmant
qu'une autre centrale pourrait fermer à
la place de fessenheim une centrale du
même âge construite dans les années 70
c'est le cas de gravelines des sites
nucléaires en france où on peut fermer
deux réacteurs sans que ça sous-entendre
qu'on ferme le sait qui dans sa totalité
mais il n'y a pas 36 ans donc les gens
ont vite fait le compte
et il ya en tête de gondole
il y a
gravelines avec ses six réacteurs donc
immédiatement ici tout le monde a
compris la menace que cela pouvait
représenter
et en ce qui nous concerne on est
immédiatement monté au créneau en disant
que pour nous cette mesure nous
paraissait absolument inacceptable
depuis élus et syndicats se mobilisent
ce jour là une réunion est organisée à
la mairie de gravelines et c'est
l'avenir de la centrale qui est au coeur
des discussions
non
l'accord ne vont pas mettre à chanter
carla joray sans que à chaque maman nous
conte ses forces sur leurs craintes que
la fermeture de gravelines ne détruisent
des emplois aujourd'hui la centrale en
gauche près de 1600 salariés
j'y suis depuis 1982 quand vous voyez ce
qui se passe à central des jeunes à peu
près une centaine de jeunes parents ça
draine plein dans peau autour la sous
traitance les contrats d'apprentissage
on est à peu près à 50 comprendre le
projet sage chopard apprend 80% soit
embauché oui à une réelle dynamique
la centrale doit être modernisé avec pas
moins de 3 milliards d'euros
d'investissements prévus par edf dans
les dix ans à venir
cette loi même si elle doit prendre en
compte des nouvelles préoccupations de
j'entends bien doit en tenir compte de
l'état de noël de nos installations
c'est ça le vrai critère la fiabilité et
la sûreté des installations au delà des
a sonné je dirais que je qualifierais
parfois deux
démagogique
pour la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat la loi sur la
transition énergétique des flous car
rien ne figure sur la fermeture des
centrales je souhaiterais que ce fruit
très juste sur cette question
si on vise principalement et 50% dire
qu'on va fermer
il ya de villepin sait combien cette
double question est ce que c'est
possible et surtout est-ce que c'est
raisonnable
la question est posée au directeur de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
celle agences chargées au nom de l'état
de contrôler la sécurité de nos
installations pour l'asn le véritable
enjeu est la fin de vie de nos réacteurs
qui fait trop entre 2020 et 2030 leurs
40 ans l'âge limite prévue lors de leur
construction fait que des centrales qui
font qu'ils vieillissent il ya des cuves
de réacteurs qui vieillissent donc ça il
faut que comme nous les américains de
traite
mais une fois que ces traités
effectivement ça peut aller très loin
nous avons effectivement une exigence
qui est différente pas simplement france
et en europe qui est d'aller vers un
niveau de sûreté supérieur pourquoi
quelle est l'alternative dans le domaine
du nucléaire à la prolongation
je précise bien dans le domaine du
nucléaire sans construire des nouvelles
je n'imagine pas qu'on compris des
nouvelles aux normes anciennes
la sûreté des centrales est contrôlé
tous les dix ans mais l'accident de
fukushima en 2011 a changé la donne
les 19 centrales françaises vont devoir
subir d'importants travaux pour mettre
les réacteurs aux nouvelles normes de
sécurité
et d'après l'asn la france ne serait pas
prête à faire face à un accident
nucléaire
il faut pas faire de sûreté ça soit
correcte mais ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'ils aient des améliorations de sûreté
qui soit apportée aux centrales
nucléaires
c'est tout l'enjeu des discussions que
nous avons engagé avec edf et sur
lesquels nous rendrons notre avis en
2018 mais déjà edf affirme vouloir
prolonger la durée de vie du parc
nucléaire
le parc nucléaire existant en france
aujourd'hui à 30 ans d'âge moyen et je
suis confiant dans la capacité qu edf en
tant que groupe industriel la capacité
d'edf à prolonger avec ses grands
partenaires en toute sécurité
la durée de fonctionnement de ce parc
jusqu'à 50 ans voire jusqu'à 60 ans et
je soulignerai que les grands
électriciens américains qui exploitent
des centrales de même technologie ont
déjà pour la majeure partie d'entre eux
obtenu des autorisations d'exploitation
jusqu'à 60 ans et on parle maintenant
éventuellement d'aller même au delà
d'après les experts pourtant certains
équipements sont irréparables comme les
cuves et enceinte de réacteurs prolonger
les centrales passe par la réalisation
d'opérations complexes sans garantie de
réussite technique mais edf n'envisage
aucune fermeture de centrales le choix
du nucléaire il ya une quarantaine
d'années a donné à la france un avantage
durable
nous avons devant nous
l'allongement de la durée de vie de nos
centrales nucléaires c'est un programme
que nous allons progressivement engagé
ces prochaines années on l'appelle grand
carénage
il a des bénéfices également en matière
de sûreté
comme vous le savez le grand carénage un
programme pour moderniser et prolonger
la durée de vie des centrales edf
prévoit pour cela à 55 milliards d'euros
d'investissements sur dix ans quand la
cour des comptes évoque le double soit
110 milliards
jean bernard lévy rejette ce chiffre ces
coûts incluent les perspectives
d'allongement avec aussi un renforcement
des dispositifs de sûreté au sein des
centrales il n'y a pas de différences
d'appréciation entre la cour des comptes
et voilà merci
d'après la cour des comptes pourtant les
55 milliards d'euros d'edf n'inclut pas
les travaux de prolongation des
centrales améliorer les conditions de
sûreté de nos centrales va coûter cher
prolonger leur durée de vie aussi un des
risques c'est que l'on dépense beaucoup
d'argent pour maintenir en vie des
centrales à g et c'est autant d'argent
qui n'est pas dédié la construction de
nouvelles centrales
l'institut de sûreté nucléaire et
l'expert français en matière de
recherches sur les risques
pour son président il est urgent pour
l'état de décider rapidement de l'avenir
de nos centrales ces centrales même si
on les prolonge dans vingt ans elles
vont toutes arrivées à leurs vrais
termes de vies et alors nous serons
devant une montagne de réinvestissement
et sert aussi que c'était une dimension
qu'il faut prendre en compte des
investissements qui ont des conséquences
sur le coût du nucléaire + 20 % depuis
2010 et le coût ne devrait cesser
d'augmenter
ce qui ne sera pas sans impact sur la
facture d'électricité des français
alors que la loi de transition
énergétique est discutée au sénat la
commission des affaires économiques a
été saisie au fond de l'ensemble du
projet de loi relatifs à la transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte
ségolène royal se prononce pour la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
une nouvelle génération de centrales
pour remplacer les anciennes quand elles
ne pourront plus être rénové
une bonne nouvelle pour le rapporteur
qui voient dans cette annonce
la relance du nucléaire
on est pour chien assez autonomes la
dépendance
si on écoute tout ce qu'elle dit oui
mais quel type de centrale pour
remplacer les anciennes la mise en
service de le p r de flamanville dans la
manche réacteur de 3e génération a déjà
été repoussée trois fois beaucoup
dénoncent un gouffre financier
le père c'est un réacteur qui n'est pas
du tout dimensionné pour les marchés de
l'énergie
aujourd'hui si on prend les estimations
de la cour des comptes on est autour de
prêt entre 50 et 55 euros du
mégawattheure si on devait demain
remplacer sa part des opm il faudrait
doubler ce prix là donc ça veut dire que
la facture des entreprises des
particuliers du blu ray
oh
retour au sénat ou en séance la
discussion de l'article 1er sur la
baisse de la part du nucléaire de 75 à
50% en 2025 vire à l'affrontement
politique
fixer des objectifs dans la loi qui ne
sont en réalité que les termes d'un
accord politique ne peut que conduire à
une terrible impasse la fia nucléaire
qui représente un des fleurons d'un
outil française et les gisements non
négligeable d'emploi garantit
l'indépendance d'haïti la france par
ailleurs quoi qu'en dise le coût du
nucléaire demeure compétitif par rapport
à celui des énergies renouvelables grâce
à un parc légèrement amortie les verts
affirment le contraire que c'est une
énergie de moins en moins rentable renom
dantec qui a présenté façon très
caricatural le site les difficultés de
la filière nucléaire s'invite dans les
débats
je suis un petit peu surpris par la
teneur du débat puisque il me semble que
fin j'ai pu rater quelqu'un mais
personne n'a encore parlé de
l'endettement d'edf 40 milliards 40
milliards personne n'a encore parlé du
coût cumulé de ces fameuses trente sept
tranches entre 2020 et 2025 pour
justement les prolonger de vingt ans un
milliard un milliard et demi la bête ça
va dire c'est l'asn qui définira les
travaux faites le calcul rapidement on
va doubler
l'endettement d'edf on va passer à 80
milliards vous pensez vraiment que c'est
raisonnable ça n'est pas raisonnable ça
n'est absolument pas raisonnable nous
avons une filière nucléaire en
souffrance économique
aujourd'hui personne n'en parle nous
n'aurons pas les moyens en 2025 avec le
niveau d'endettement d'edf de prolonger
l'ensemble des tranches
nous le savons tous et nous sommes tous
dans la posture comme quoi le monde
allait parfaitement bien ça n'est pas
vrai
areva aussi est en difficulté le géant
du nucléaire affiche près de 5 milliards
d'euros de pertes un déficit historique
qui engage sa survie n'importe quelle
entreprise privée avec un passif pareil
serait déjà en faillite mais fort d'une
entreprise qui appartient à 85 % à
l'état qui soutient le son son
développement et donc elle elle tient
grâce à ça mais on est là aussi en train
de décaler pas mal de décisions qui vont
être très douloureuses c'est
qu'aujourd'hui areva n'a pu va devoir
subir une très importante
restructuration qui a toujours été
décalé qui est fort été repoussée
la faute selon areva au chantier de le p
r finlandais qui accusent neuf ans de
retard
et au marché nucléaire japonais à
l'arrêt depuis fukushima duquel dépend
des beaucoup le groupe sature espérer un
redémarrage se sentent régulière pour
plus rapide que ça a été le cas ça veut
dire que la profession pas le japon en
combustible nous retraiterons pas de ne
convertis soient pas et donc c'est un
marché qui propose un problème éthique
explique le trou d'air en quelque sorte
qu'elle vénère évacuer les tickets
envers le projet nous avions une crainte
très forte que la loi ne prévoit la
fermeture sèche des centrales nucléaires
s'il n'est pas le cas et cela nous
paraît primordial pour areva
ce texte réaffirme la place primordiale
du nucléaire dans le mix énergie pas
inquiet par la loi le directeur des
affaires publiques d'areva il ne redoute
pas les fermetures de centrales
c'est pourtant cette crainte qui a
poussé la majorité du sénat a modifié le
texte d'accord pour baisser la part du
nucléaire à 50% mais sans fixer de date
butoir
l'objectif de 50% ne nous contrarie pas
en revanche la date de 2025 est une date
irréaliste le délai pendant lequel il
faudrait fermer 20 réacteurs est
impossible à tenir
ce qui compte pour nous c'est le contenu
ce n'est pas le climat général et nous
considérons que le texte qui nous est
proposée va dans le bon sens le säntis
ans du sénat ne peut pas tenir bien
longtemps
le projet reste bien de rester à
l'ancien costume du modèle énergétique
français dont certains ici encore la
nostalgie
malgré ces mesures et le coût faramineux
de son entretien
nous préférons donc retravaillé avec la
proposition initiale de l'assemblée
nationale conforme aux croquis du
président de la république
un autre amendement du sénat change la
nature de la loi le plafonnement de la
puissance du parc nucléaire à 64,85 giga
watts au lieu des 60 3,2 prévus
initialement
le chiffre n'est pas choisi au hasard
il permettrait d'ouvrir le payeur de
flamanville sans arrêté aucun des 58
réacteurs actuels et donc au final
d'accroître la production nucléaire au
lieu de ta diminuer les frais
des reculs inacceptable pour les ong qui
dénoncent une loi vidé de sa substance
par les sénateurs très loin de
l'ambition initiale l on va aller vers
50% de part du nucléaire dans la
production d'électricité et en même
temps il hausse le plafond de la
puissance installée en france elle
augmente à court terme pour dire qu'on
va réduire un jour ça fait pas très
crédible et les ong et les écologistes
demandent à ségolène royal de rester
ferme sur les objectifs de la loi
cependant une logique partisane conseil
des observations qui consiste à monnayer
telle ou telle décision pour telle ou
telle posture politique ça va être
totalement adif indifférent est ce que
je veux c'est aller de l'avant ségolène
royal en quête d'un compromis
déterminé à ce que la loi de transition
énergétique soit votée rapidement
la ministre de l'ecologie tente de
rassurer je ne ferai pas de polémique je
ne veux pas que je ne veux pas que le
nucléaire coûte les postures
idéologiques soient prises en otages
près de la loi en otage on sent qu'elle
n'est pas très à l'aise sur le sujet à
la fois il ya un engagement du président
de la république qui était très clair
50% de part du nucléaire dans la
production d'électricité en 2025 donc la
date était actée et elle a été répété de
nombreuses fois et à la fois on sent que
la ministre elle voilà ne serait pas
contre finalement aller vers un délai
plus long voire pas de délai quelque
part la question du nucléaire est
tellement clivante et elle est tellement
san en quelque sorte du consensus
qu'elle n'a pas envie de rentrer dans ce
sujet clivant
au scrutin public sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi relatifs à la transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte
ce que tu as ouvert dans quelques
instants la chasse
mais mais on est on est tellement
pressés car après tout rien du squeeze
le sénat adopte donc un projet de loi de
transition énergétique largement retoqué
à une large majorité sans baisse du
nucléaire 184 voix pour et 34 contre
avec l'abstention du groupe socialiste
donc le sénat a adopté le projet de loi
relatifs à la transition énergétique
pour la croissance verte satisfaites
la droite compte bien se faire entendre
même si ce n'est pas le sénat qui aura
le dernier mot
mais bien le gouvernement et l'assemblée
nationale qui défendent le texte initial
je ne lâcherai pas le bon moment si
vraiment cette majorité maintient sa
volonté de fermer 20 des acteurs d'ici
2025 je monte au créneau et je commence
ma campagne que le gouvernement nous
dise tout de suite
quels sont les centrales qui vont
exceller de secours ne ferme pas comme
ça miraculeusement 20 centrales du jour
au lendemain en 2025
c'est maintenant qu'il faut commencer à
préparer les premières fermetures de
manière à ce que ça intervienne et donc
je demanderai je ne lâcherai pas le jour
en jour chaque jour les cannes et à
partir de quand
imaginons un seul instant que dans les
années 70 ça s'est poursuivi dans les
années 80 on n'est pas construit ce parc
électronucléaire ou sur d'immenses
difficultés et d'avoir d'un point de vue
économique la majorité ump du sénat a
fait preuve d'un grand dogmatismes c'est
à dire avec le retour d'un discours sur
le tout-nucléaire triomphant qui nous
rappelle les années 60 70 ce qui ne
correspond plus à aucune réalité c'est
un discours totalement fantasmée